est ce que par exemple vous pourriez
manger des insectes vivent probablement
que non je pense que mon ressenti et est
relativement similaire le macarou avec
deux arts est une arnaque un qu'on soit
bien d'accord
pourquoi parce que réfléchissent aussi
si vous mangez un macaron de goût citron
par exemple ou afficher quand elle est
bien seul coeur du macaron a un goût de
citron le biscuit n'a pas de goût de
citron
voyez le problème est quand vous êtes un
peu sensible à la fois sur le plan
gustatif à la fois sensible aux
mensonges
ça peut être une difficulté majeure de
l'idée de créer des macarons autistes
c'est à dire des macarons qui tiennent
leurs promesses et qui sont
véritablement au goût de citron durant
mes tendres et jeunes années eh bien il
était à peu près impossible de me faire
manger quoi que ce soit et j'étais par
exemple gravement anorexique comme
d'autres personnes autistes d'ailleurs
[Musique]
procéder à une sorte de microchirurgie
du jambon avant de tenter de le manger
c'est à dire d'enlever tous les
filaments blancs la difficulté étant de
canto n'est pas très habile comme
c'était notamment mon cas la procédure
peut prendre des heures et à l'arrivée
il n'y a plus de jambon et on n'a
toujours pas mangé beaucoup de personnes
autistes régulièrement parmi les adultes
sont par exemple adepte d'un certain
type d'alimentation par exemple des
végétariens ou par exemple des gens même
qui refuse toutes les aliments cuits et
il ya aussi divers enfants qui ne
mangent que des aliments d'une certaine
couleur ou avec une certaine température
ou avec une certaine présentation
[Musique]
or à chaque difficulté à chaque obstacle
à avec un petit coup de génie on peut
trouver une solution